last question for today hey David why do
we call American billionaires
billionaires and Russian billionaires
oligarchs good question clever question
for me the answer is one word impunity
George Soros Warren Buffett Bill Gates
in the context of the United States of
America rich people have a ton of power
but they can't act with impunity
in the way that Russian oligarchs act
with impunity within Russia that that's
the big difference for me right and this
is sort of you you you can start to
slice it in different ways but there is
a security that the Russian oligarch has
at least in operating within their
country that somebody like Warren
Buffett or Elon Musk or Bill Gates
doesn't have within the United States
there's no question that we have
basically two countries we've got a
country for rich people in a country for
everybody else justice system law
enforcement relationship banking all
sorts of stuff right there's no question
about it but when I think about that
word impunity that for me is the
difference between a Russian oligarch
and an American billionaire and we we
could go you know into more detail and
then sort of think about other specific
differences but the ways in which even
the Koch brothers or Soros use their
power in the United States there's still
a little bit more of a framework and
parameters around which they can use
that power that I think when you talk
about an oligarch isn't really there
that that that's sort of my thought and
I don't know if you have any strong
feelings pat about whether you think
maybe american billion billionaires are
oligarchs in in the sort of russian
sense but i keep going back to the idea
of acting with impunity and that's where
the difference really is from it yeah
maybe they ought to be considered
oligarchs but we just haven't assigned
that name to him yet i know there are
many you know studies out there and
people have been saying for a long time
that the united states because of our
campaign finance system operates more
like an oleg Archy than a democracy
which it's supposed to sure so i
think it's a pretty fitting term maybe
we should start embracing it there's
another idea that the oleg arc is so
tied in and friendly with government
that they're sort of like getting
kickbacks with government and there's
not a clear line between whether an
oligarch is involved in private business
or an or in state business you can make
the case that that sort of exists in the
United States that the American
billionaire with a super successful
corporation they can make deals with the
government where there may not be
literal kickbacks but there's sort of
kickbacks of convenience if not of money
but I think that there is somewhat of a
difference there as well right like when
you look in Russia at some of the banks
and some of them energy companies
there's almost no division whatsoever
between whether the head of that company
is a private CEO or someone working for
the Kremlin and oftentimes it's kind of
a combination of both and that's that's
a fair difference I think as well
although it's kind of a matter of
degrees because it does exist within the
United States also we've got a great
bonus show for you today sign up for
membership at WWE at muncom or become a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show to get instant access to the
world-famous bonus show I'll speak to
you then